the Olaf Apple morale is a condominium
with a difference with sky terraces
fronting every floor
these unique apartments are expressed as
angles in the air instead of rules as
restrictions the Oliver's an example of
how projects can turn regulations into
opportunities for high-density living in
Singapore the sky terraces not only
stretch the idea of communal living they
also provide opportunities for
architectural expressions the result is
a striking lush of greenery that lines
both the front and rear facades of the
apartments the olive pushes this to the
limits by spreading it throughout the
entire building each floor consists of
two Mason 'its sharing a sky terrace
which is accessible by another set of
common lives the 7 meter high Sky
Terrace is a covered and landscaped
outdoor space which creates a feeling of
an extended exterior here the gardens
are no longer limited to the ground
floor but also appear on every floor the
under sites are cast in texture or form
concrete now the floor is finished in
natural balla complete with recessed
planter boxes that house the lush
gardens the client TD Development wonder
a unique development that would appeal
to consumers they recognized a unique
design of the olive and how it fulfills
its demands while adding to the
residents quality of life the Breivik's
plot the sky terraces potential and how
it can be better enjoyed by the
occupants sky terraces and double volume
living spaces are nothing new the
challenge was to create it in an
architectural unique way that was also
functional and livable
the other is a bold statement with a
unique design that challenges the norm
and pushes Singapore architecture
forward
you